all right I'm Michael Netsky and I'm
going to be talking to you about
how Yale might use machine learning to
create content faster and smarter I
started out as an internal presentation
and it was a little bit more low-key but
on Frances advice stealing from Michael
Mike Connolly from from his presentation
yesterday
AI is set to transform industries and
including communications it is expected
to be a one point four to two point six
trillion dollar transformation for just
the marketing communications industry in
the next few years and it's one of those
technologies that seems like it's in the
future or something that's going to be
coming down the pipe or something that's
frankly in science fiction but really
it's something that organizations are
using today in their communication plans
and there's a lot of a lot of
opportunities right away so I'm Mike von
etske I'm the director of technology at
four kitchens and four kitchens we're a
digital agency that creates websites
apps and software for organizations that
need to tell important stories we've
been around for 13 years and I've served
a sophisticated clientele including Yale
as their trusted digital partner to
realize and exceed their goals for
kitchens web chefs believe that creating
a website is like preparing a feast it
requires a team of people with
specialized and complementary skills
working in concert to create something
with lots the lots of people will enjoy
its part art part science and it's all
about preparation so what I'm gonna try
to dive into today is defining a few
terms around machine learning and
artificial intelligence talking a little
bit about what
how news organizations are doing things
that you would only expect to see in
science fiction today diving into some
of the ways that it can be utilized here
at Yale or on any CMS and then really
hopefully get people thinking about how
it might be used in the future so what
I'm not going to talk about is I'm going
to stick only to the editorial process
and how it really effects editors but
three key areas where it really where
there are huge opportunities and where
it's being utilized today are in
personalization that's probably the one
thing that people first think of when
they think of how AI and content kind of
go together the other one is in
analytics excuse me
and in chatbots those each one of those
could be its own presentation and so
that's really the reason we're leaving
it up today and then also and if
everybody works the CMS knows that it
doesn't get nearly as much love as some
of those other things so just to kind of
define some terms machine learning so
it's a it's a from Wikipedia it's a
category of algorithm that allows
software applications to become more
accurate and predicting outcomes without
being explicitly programmed it's it's
really kind of bringing statistics into
the things that you traditionally think
computer programming is doing and it
opens up some interesting opportunities
because of that artificial intelligence
I mean is kind of the blanket term but
they get used entertain changeably and
depending on kind of who's speaking in
who the audience is honestly like lots
of technical people will use machine
learning the marketing people are gonna
use AI because it sounds cooler and then
a fairly big part of this and a lot of
the opportunities that are coming from
content come from natural language
processing so that's artificial
intelligence that helps computers
understand interpret and manipulate
human language
more about how it how it does that as we
go one way that helped me understand
kind of the difference between the
machine learning and kind of like what
we traditionally think of programming is
to kind of compare the two so in in
programming when you're computer
programming you have data so you have
like data coming from a database or
something else or input by a user and
you have rules so like those are the
functions that you write as a programmer
like if-then statements all that and
then you combine those together and you
get out predictable output because it's
written by humans it's mostly
predictable output but you know there
ways to write tests and to make it make
it better and and the rules are written
by humans so like when you're
programming computer like there's like
you you can kind of trace back in and
step through it and and understand
exactly what it's doing in contrast the
machine learning is data so whatever
data you're putting into the system and
then statistical models that output
results with confidence scores and
that's kind of it's a lot different than
the than programming which is really
deterministic but in AI and the outputs
of AI you get a lot that you get a
you'll get a result that is 50% won and
50% or another or 90% won ten percent of
another and the model is the statistical
models they're built from examples and
there's not a there's a black box
element to it so you're not actually
like manipulating the the outputs
directly and you really can't step
through them and and easily understand
the logic that is going into it which is
kind of a fundamental difference between
them it's what opens up a lot of the
opportunities that AI opens up but it
also creates its own set of problems
so what is it good at it's good at
finding and following patterns and then
making predictions based on those
patterns and that those predictions and
those patterns they can be in things are
really squishy like what's inside of an
image it can also be really or like what
somebody is trying to say when they're
using words to communicate and making
predictions so like based on the huge
amount of data that you put in you if
you put this one piece of data into it
you expect it to come out this this way
it gets better over time
and as models are refined and you're
kind of we're all kind of experiencing
this as it goes particularly with like
big companies like Google as it's
getting better at reading our email and
understanding like what we're trying to
say when we're talking to our Google
home things like that and really the the
biggest fundamental difference and
biggest fundamental opportunity that
that machine learning and AI provides is
that it's the first time that computers
and content management systems can
really see into the complex stuff that
that our images or human-like human to
human communication before sorry before
that was like kind of management's and
it's just like a is it's a place where
you'd put stuff but really has no idea
what's in there um and it kind of
doesn't care and this is the first time
where your content management system can
start to actually read what you write so
like there's some risks are there things
that are not good at the building of
models takes time in iteration so it's
not it's because it's not not
deterministic it takes like creating
models testing them out seeing what the
outputs are like and an experimentation
it can very easily amplify bias and I'm
sure everybody here has heard stories
about how facial recognition doesn't
work people of color
and and things like that and that's
that's a very real concern and the other
one is that it really to really get good
it requires very vast data sets and
constant cultivation and for most small
organizations like though those are kind
of the stumbling blocks and where AI and
machine learning
don't become viable solutions but
there's lots of ways to sort of tap into
the work that companies like Google and
Microsoft are doing in this space to get
access to those really big datasets and
sort of the outputs over so the Cassie
KO's and I think polish a thing I think
I'd be good at pronouncing that but I
can't so I'm gonna give up but so it
puts it this way like our are you in the
business of baking bread or making ovens
right and in this case like the the
ovens are being made by Google and by
Microsoft and you're kind of putting
stuff into it and you know putting dough
into it and and getting bread back
that's a good way to look at it so as I
said before content management systems
today don't know and really don't care
what you put in them they might have
some some rules around the number of
characters that a piece of content has
but if it's a story about birds or if
it's a story about what happened last
week in a at a sports game it really it
really doesn't know unless you tell it
unless you tag it right what what
changes with AI and machine learning is
for the first time like the content
management system can really read and
see what's in your content and that
seems kind of futuristic but we're like
literally living with this stuff in our
daily lives more so probably than we are
living with the stuff in our CMS's
so major publishers are already writing
content that's being published on their
publications in their print publications
even that is a hundred percent created
by machines
so the Washington Post has a a bot
called heliograph
and what it does is it writes summaries
of little league games across the
country and that's a beat that nobody
could really keep up with and they
wouldn't be able to support otherwise
but with AI they are able to take the
data from from the events meaning like
who won who lost how many people were on
base etc and write a story about that
based on a template forbes has bertie
which is a new content management system
and and what it does is it uses machine
learning and AI to suggest better
headlines and find images that are
relevant to the content that's being
written so eliminates and the menial
tasks and then Bloomberg kind of
famously has what they call kind of
ominously cyborg which takes financial
statements from companies and creates
news articles based on those so those
are I mean these are things that are
happening right now like these are
articles you're reading today the last
project that I want to mention is it's
called radar from the BBC and what it
does is it creates localized content to
make it more relevant and more poignant
for people in different parts of England
so if it's a story about homelessness
when it gets to the part about
statistics and you're in Bristol it'll
talk about the homeless homelessness
problem in in Bristol and if you're in
London it'll talk about the homeless
problem it'll use the statistics from
London to make that story more relevant
to you as the user I thought was one of
the most fascinating sort of
applications of this
another place that this is just showing
up that is kind of surprisingly
effective is in Google photos so if you
type into the search bar almost any word
in Google photos you will get back your
photos that have been tagged by Google
for that word so here I look for pink if
you look for dogs if you look for girls
if you look for China or Japan all those
things come up without any tagging on my
part or any interaction and if you use
google photos you might have noticed
that there is a an aspect of it and
these days where it kind of puts
together stories for you based on the
images that kind of go together and so
it's kind of helping you create content
without you having to actually sit there
and organize and go through all the
photos and figure out like which ones
are the good ones or which ones go
together it's also able to help you
write is gonna be here besides me use
grammarly yeah yeah a few yeah any I
mean it it works it works well it has
relevant suggestions it it's a it reads
content that you put into it kind of
integrates with with your Gmail and with
your editor and things like that and
this is a similar kind of lower-cost
thing called Hemingway and it's not just
sort of it's not it's not just
low-hanging fruit it's it's it's looking
for sentences that are too long it's
also looking for words that are less
effective and elevating your writing and
not just choose excuse me
locking it into a set of rules
Google is also working on a API
moderation tools - with the New York
Times to help cut down the amount of
toxicity in the comments that are made
on articles so with this API they're
creating tools that automatically give
the feedback to writers and also provide
ways for moderators to more quickly
engage with the content so that's so
that's kind of like that that's the
that's a I in in the broader world and
and what's what's happening kind of
outside of our little ecosystem there
are a number of Drupal modules that do
some nascent things but like nothing
nothing nearly as interesting honestly
as some of the things we've talked about
here one of them that's a really low
hanging fruit and probably a frustration
that everybody in this room has had is
creating a alternative text there's also
a very nascent google cloud vision
integration that pulls in the the
tagging capabilities and will actually
tag your images that you upload to
Drupal with all the same tags that I was
talking about in in Google photos so if
you upload a picture of a girl or a
picture that has the color pink in it in
your CMS those will also be tagged so
you can more easily find them and attach
them to content there's also a set of
tools called intelligent content tools
and and they require installing Python
and some flasks and stuff like that but
once you get it running it'll actually
do automatic summaries for you which is
pretty fascinating and pretty
interesting
I haven't played around with it directly
but it does look like it does like it
does what it says on the box and this is
just the start so in a way I think it's
not that a it's not that they're like AI
isn't being used for content creation
it's that these tools kind of aren't
filtering down into the layer that we
live in right
so next I want to jump into a little bit
of like what these api's are like and
what can be leveraged and and where we
can kind of go immediately in in in the
near future and because this is
something that we've been thinking about
we created a demo called
happy gram AI and you can actually try
it out
later today and what it does is it
collects a happy moment from you and
then Allah strangers from unsplash using
some of the api's that I'm talking about
it's a kind of a fun way to kind of see
what is potentially possible but also
showcases how you can use these
technologies to make content creation
more streamlined so I'm going to be
talking about the the tools that Google
provides but all the cloud providers
including AWS and Microsoft Azure and
Google and IBM Watson all have these
capabilities and they're very comparable
between them there's kind of subtle
differences in the capabilities subtle
differences and what it what they do and
pricing but they like it's really
interchangeable and depending on which
yeah which platform you're on they're
there they're probably available so the
first one is the Google natural language
processing tools and what they do is
that they give you a lot of analysis of
text that you put into it
so they an analyze sentiment so telling
you how positive or negative a piece of
content is that we useful for things
like moderation of comments also in
trying to understand customer
interactions with you but also can be a
tool for writers if they're to be able
to kind of provide them with feedback
about the content that they're writing
right if they think that they're writing
something happy but Google comes back
and says it's not really that happy it
could be a sign that you know there's
different way to word things it provides
a very in-depth analysis of the parts of
speech
and what content is about but then also
how the different words are linked
together and you have a very very
detailed set of tools to be able to kind
of pull out phrases and associations of
words in it there's a very global
content classification that happens and
and you can see like in Google there's
like links to the Wikipedia articles and
etc and also it provides the most
salient topics in a piece of text and
seeing this in action is is pretty
impressive because it's not like we're
kind of used to that with keywords or
like with a search or something like
that but this is different so this is
what the content is is really about and
it's prioritized based on how important
the nouns or the subjects or the
entities as it calls it are in the parts
of speech the next API that's probably
the most useful out of these and the
lowest hanging fruit that's kind of
immediately available and also really
easy because there's already a Drupal
integration is it's an API that
classifies the contents of image it
extracts objects from the images and
I'll just move to the slides it's
puppies anyway and it does a
surprisingly good job of this so so the
things that like impress me a bit like
when I when I tried this out is not that
it finds a dog but if you but that it
tags all three of the dogs that are in
this so to the dogs you can't see their
faces they're looking away and the back
one like it's you know like it's almost
question more that's a cat or not right
the other thing that it that it finds is
that these are Labrador retrievers which
is actually questionable in some ways
but is surprisingly accurate and then
finally that it identifies that that
they're in a kennel
and and to me that's kind of interesting
because you can't really tell this the
shape of a kennel or something like that
it's just I guess dogs with vertical
bars in front of it get you know have a
very high probability of being in a
kennel so I mean that's in digging into
these things and you can try them out on
on their website it is surprisingly
powerful and surprisingly accurate the
the last tool is probably the most
powerful and the one that can provide
the the biggest advantage is to to
content creators and it's called Auto ml
and what it is it is it is a tool that
takes all the complexity out of building
your own machine learning models and
gets it out of your way
it works by you tagging your content a
portion of it as the learning model
that's going to use and then uploading
all of your content and then just
running the algorithm through it you can
see when if you try the demo up later
today we use it to categorize happy
moments and there's about seven
categories and it's right almost every
single time which is like it's it's
fascinating and that can be used to take
content that your editors are putting in
and tag it with with your with your
taxonomy it can also be used to tag it
with a taxonomy that or a range of
techniques on amis that would be
completely pedantic and a huge burden on
your users so I don't know if anybody
here has like a complicated taxonomy and
that there's like fights around well is
it really belong and this or does it
belong and that and like one person is
tagging things one way but then another
person is tagging things another way and
it creates a mess in
and makes the content difficult to find
using this tool that can all be
automated and editors can just go back
to just writing and not having to worry
about all of that types of content the
other thing that it can really help with
is with with SEO so being able to take
take content and then provide and
automatically attach all the metadata
that Google or Facebook is looking for
and take that out of the the writers way
so so so that's so those are some of the
different ways that the like those are
some of the things that are available
but broadly what what can it do so we
can automate menial tasks so taking
things like classification writing
metadata attaching alt text out of the
the writers of the content creators
day-to-day even starting to do things
like the summarize text it can also
combine data with templates in a much
smarter way then you can now so right
now you can you can sort of say that
like oh well this isn't me content this
main image and you kind of like you put
it into places and it all fits together
but instead now back and go a layer
deeper and do something like the BBC
where instead of talking about you can
localize the content and talk about
statistics that are relevant to the
users or write one article use it in
different schools across the across
campus and replace the relevant
information intelligently it can also
provide very deep analysis of the
content and very unbiased analysis of
the content so tools like Hemingway and
grammarly can provide feedback to
writers
about how their writing is how effective
it is and how it's working but it can
also provide a an entry point to all the
the media that's being used across
campus and centralize it and tag it in
ways that make it useful to other parts
of the campus so like when that like
going back to that the picture of the
puppies inside the inside the kennel
probably very likely that if you have a
very disciplined content creation team
that like if they were uploading that
image that they would tag it as dogs
maybe tag it as puppies but it's
unlikely that and and where they took it
and things like that probably but it's
unlikely that they would actually tag
that image with the fact that they're in
a kennel that's kind of like a weird
detail that Google picked picks up on
but as you're like if it wasn't a if it
wasn't an article about kennels that
would probably never come up in the
right in in the in the mind of the
content creator right but here it's just
very pedantically and and very very
deeply sort of looking at what's there
comparing to the things that seemed
before and telling you what it thinks it
is there another way that this can be
leveraged is to provide suggestions to
improve content and take the the
analytics data that's coming in and
provide suggestions as to what kinds of
headlines or how headlines can be
reworded so that they are more effective
when the content goes out and then
finally a deep categorization and a very
unbiased categorization of content
so so these are all the things that like
are possible or can be done with machine
learning and AI but there's one very big
caveat and that when creating models or
putting information into a machine
learning model it is imperative that you
really look at very deeply into what
you're putting into it because it's a
black box it really it doesn't it
doesn't lend itself to easily scrutiny
and can it's very easy to create not
just one piece of content or one piece
of or one image that's that's biased or
that doesn't speak to everyone but
really kind of create that problem
across campus and with movement when
you're doing things like making
suggestions to improve content or we're
suggesting images that can really
reinforce the biases that are made by
the people who are creating those models
right and it'll happen in subtle ways
and it also happened in in my on a much
grander scale than just one person
writing one article and that's the that
that's that's why ethics and AI really
kind of go together as a conversation it
comes up in the news this way but it's
and it's but it's not a it's not a flood
and it's not a it's not an exaggeration
like this is like it literally is a tool
to automate and disseminate by us Google
and all the other and Amazon both have
extensive portions about their ethics
and how they're approaching it and it's
going to work if you're kind of diving
into this stuff to really kind of take a
look at how they're approaching this and
and and and the mistakes that they've
already made
that's it
[Applause]
[Music]